l'objectif 0 déchet est toujours dans
l'air du temps mais la pandémie a mis un
frein supplémentaire à ce mode de vie
exigeant mais satisfaisant et André
Langlois s'est demandé qu'est-ce que ça
prendrait pour qu'il y ait plus de
consommateurs qui soient sensibilisés
par cette façon de faire
dans ce petit commerce de quartier les
clients ont le choix d'acheter plusieurs
aliments en vrac et sans emballage je
fais quelque chose entre que pour
l'environnement
c'est emballage aussi sans que c'est la
même chose nous on existe depuis 8 ans
et ça commençait par une petite épicerie
traditionnelle qui s'est converti en
épicerie zéro déchet c'est ça qui fait
notre différence donc on était capable
de sauter vers une un nouveau mode de
vie donc on est devenu un exemple pour
n'importe quelle épicerie traditionnelle
qui peut aller vers une épicerie zéro
déchet
[Musique]
dans les épiceries traditionnelles on
trouve beaucoup d'emballages et très peu
de vrac parfois un comptoir de livre un
présentoir de café alors que c'est près
de 80% des consommateurs canadien qui
font leur épicerie dans les supermarchés
des grandes enseignes c'est donc dire
que c'est à cet endroit-là qu'il faut
rendre l'offre accessible et non
uniquement dans les commerces
spécialisés et le supermarché mais ça
permet de faire toutes les courses aussi
je pense que c'est pour des raisons
pratiques qu'on va notamment à
l'épicerie
Amélie côté est analyste chez equitaire
selon un rapport de l'organisme le zéro
déchet doit être accessible à tous
surtout que plusieurs emballages ne
seraient pas recyclables
sur les 1.9 millions de tonnes
d'emballage de plastique mis en marché
au Canada à chaque année ça c'est
l'équivalent de 150 000 autobus
scolaires en termes de poids il y en a
57% qui n'est même pas recyclable
de plus très souvent à l'épicerie
plusieurs fruits et légumes sont
emballés parfois même sur un balai et le
problème c'est qu'il y a aussi des fois
une concurrence entre le produit sans
emballage et le produit emballé puis on
va faire un paquet par exemple de 6
poivrons qui vont être moins cher que si
on les achète individuellement et au
bout du compte c'est d'abord il y a un
emballage qui est généré mais peut-être
qu'on avait pas besoin de cette quantité
là donc ça peut aussi générer du
gaspillage alimentaire on peut toujours
faire mieux effectivement pour le tous
des jeux noter certains produits des
fois qui semblaient sur un balai on peut
pas faire de cas par cas mais dans
beaucoup de cas c'est une question de
protection du de l'animal
Michel Rochette du Conseil canadien du
commerce de détails c'est aussi une
question de sécurité alimentaire on voit
déjà une offre qui est assez grande du
volume de produits qu'on peut acheter en
vrac je comprends que certains
voudraient en voir davantage mais
priorité demeure encore une fois l'enjeu
sanitaire et leur
aujourd'hui à la Maison du développement
durable Lorraine fait découvrir les
produits zéro déchets de son entreprise
qui est basée sur la consigne je pense
en effet que le zéro déchet doit être
plus simple nous notre positionnement
c'est davantage en ligne on propose une
alternative en étant un achat en ligne
complètement zéro déchet tous les
produits de base sont en général à peu
près 10% moins cher que ce que vous
allez trouver dans tous les autres
commerces par exemple j'achète du lait
ça c'est du lait qui va qui va être
exemplaires
donc c'est plus cher ça c'est certain
que l'alimentation biologique
alimentation locale artisanale ça va
toujours être un coût plus élevé que à
l'alimentation industrielle nous on a
choisi de mettre en avant ces produits
là puis on pense que cette alternative
doit toujours être mis en avant malgré
l'inflation
en ces temps déflation si certains
produits en vracent des épiceries
spécialisées peuvent parfois paraître
plus chers il faut comparer et magaziner
il est toutefois possible de faire des
économies selon Allam pendant ce temps
de crise et même sans le temps d'écrire
c'est qu'on achète seulement la quantité
dont on a besoin ça c'est vraiment
important parce que ça élimine
la consommation
inutile donc la surconsommation le
gaspillage alimentaire par exemple pour
finir le mois puis on est vraiment serré
puis on a mangé on a besoin de manger du
riz si on peut juste venir prendre notre
tasse de riz qu'on a besoin pour ce soir
à la place d'acheter un kilo les épices
c'est un bon exemple parfois un produit
emballé il y a juste 50 g de poivre et
le contenant il coûte par exemple 5
dollars mais ici ce 50 g il peut coûter
peut-être un dollar c'est quand même
assez c'est énorme comme différence il y
a 56 des personnes qui ont répondu à
notre sondage qui se disaient prêtes à
adopter un changement donc harnais par
exemple leur propre contenant à
l'épicerie pour acheter en vrac et 5%
qui le faisaient déjà mais de l'autre
côté on a l'industrie les détaillants
qui sont que d'une part la population
n'est pas prête n'est pas nécessairement
intéressé là c'est un peu le jeu de la
poule ou l'oeuvre parce que tant que
l'offre n'est pas disponible
on n'a pas de changement d'habitude à
grande échelle mais si on le développait
on pense qu'un potentiel qui serait
vraiment intéressant de ce côté là le
pouvoir d'achat des grandes chaînes
aurait une influence sur le prix qui
serait très intéressantes aussi pour
rendre le vrac plus accessible à tout le
monde alors on offre au maximum du
possible des produits en vrac il est
possible d'arriver avec des sacs
réutilisables pour notamment les fruits
et légumes donc il y a des efforts qui
sont faits là mais la priorité d'abord
la sécurité à la fois des gens du et des
animaux
malgré les efforts de l'industrie
alimentaire il peut être difficile sans
incitatif ni législation d'améliorer
davantage les choses selon équitter on
n'a pas d'obligation on n'a pas de cible
et tant qu'il n'y a pas ces objectifs là
le changement de se mettre en place les
politiques de prix peuvent influencer
en France justement il y a cette il y a
cette question là de que le produit en
vrac soit moins cher que le produit
emballé
en France par exemple avec le projet de
loi climat différentes mesures sont
prises pour encourager le zéro déchet
d'abord toutes les épiceries qui ont une
surface de 400 mètres carrés et plus
vont devoir offrir 20% de leur surface
devant en vrac d'ici 2030 donc une
mesure très concrète de ce côté-là il y
a l'obligation aussi d'appliquer une
tarification plus basse pour les gens
qui apportent leur propre contenance
l'interdiction de la vente d'emballer en
fait certains fruits et légumes le zéro
déchet ça appartient pas à une épicerie
ou un quartier ou c'est tout le monde
doit rentrer là-dedans la conscience
écologique elle est globale et non pour
certaines épiceries spécialisées il faut
que tout le monde travaille ensemble
pour trouver une solution si on se
ramène avant la pandémie là en 2019 les
grandes bannières avaient commencé à
accepter les contenants réutilisables
personnels mais c'est aussi parce qu'il
y avait un intérêt donc je pense qu'il
faut pas sous-estimer le pouvoir citoyen
et l'influence que ça a
il faut que quand on boitte le pas sur
tout le monde un client les les
épiceries de grande surface les
restaurants tout le monde tout ce qui
sert des clients il faut que ça soit
dans toujours dans la conscience
éco-responsable zéro déchet